i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning for all three of you if
someone has actually never seen anything
that you've done before what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
for me it would be
um behind the purple door
incest is relative it's a light porn
that i did when i was 18
years old now hear me out hear me out i
have a soliloquy right in the middle and
i say um i i just the office i think
the office would be for me
i guess cherise from high fidelity
patty did you do anything i think um
behind the purple door incest is
relative to
that was my first film and it was a
non-sexual role but i refused to do the
sequel she was in it and i and i nailed
it um
i guess
um doorman and
and barkeep
um
i think
i think maybe
uh
i think you should leave is pro the
thing that i've done that is most
uh
in tune to my sense of humor what i saw
you on
what sketch did you do i was the barkeep
and i was the doorman
there you have it but i did have
unsimulated sex on that one
like on the screen i think you should
leave and i think you should every
sketch a lot of it got cut
has this been any help at all
listen actually it has i like when
people can improv like that and uh and
because i could never do what you just
did
never in a million years um i love
learning about the like the behind the
scenes of the making of any movie any
show so for soon to be fans of this what
do you actually think they would be
surprised to learn about the making of
lost city
to work on a body of water is actually
very difficult and a lot of moving parts
and
there's maybe
10 boats
out there with you
and you're getting
the directors giving you notes as like
the ships are literally passing and
they're like yelling across the boat
their boat to you of like can you do
this now with
you're like what it's so it's it's wild
working on the water but it's amazing
what you end up getting from it is is
priceless but i never knew it was going
to be
that much
and i think people think
yes that was danger i think people would
be curious to know that channing tayden
and myself we have the same trainer we
do the same regiment yeah
and that's why he looks the way he does
it makes complete sense
patty has something to say
um i just want to say that you kind of
said channing's name like shannon
tanem
tannen kind of said it weird what's his
name
channing jaden
um
[Music]
you're thinking of carol channing
yeah oh that's close
um i think people would be very
surprised to know that
um
in the dr we we shot it it was
uh it was in the rainy season so there
was a lot like it's in the movies
beautiful sunny movie but they were
stopping a lot for rain and it rains
very like randomly it's super
spontaneous and it would rain super hard
for like a couple of minutes and then it
would stop and be really sunny and you
think people find that interesting
[Music]
it was hurricanes i mean it is a fact
what she says is true i just don't know
how interesting it is it's not it's the
raiding season it's freaking caribbean
sometimes i'm afraid i'm stupid
no you have nothing to fear
has it been like this all day
yeah it's whipping her a long time we've
been here since 2 a.m last night
so i i definitely want to know obviously
i'm a huge brett brad pitt fan like
everybody what was it like finding out
that brad's going to be in the movie and
then you have zero scenes with him
how do you know
there was a lot cut
a lot
a lot cut
um it was
it was really insane because it was
already insane to at the idea of like
working with
like
sandy or channing it was like oh
okay and then you're just adding them on
i think at that point i was like
where are we gonna who are we gonna have
next uh like
mussolini he's
yes the wonderful magnetic uh mussolini
you guys he's like our robert redford he
really brad pitt is like yeah he's the
guy it's it's crazy how he got there but
he's he's the fella
he's the real deal yeah and a real
trooper he came in did his job didn't
they say something about like he had to
stay an extra day and like did it
without pay like just a real
um
trooper and it's something that everyone
always talks so highly of them you know
um my last thing for you guys uh i am
i'm really impressed with with uh sandra
in her physical comedy like what she can
deliver on screen and i'm just sort of
curious can you talk a little bit about
working with her because she's so good
in this she has a very strong sense of
play
there's there's there's definitely the
child is still in her and to me that's
amazing after having such a fruitful and
long career a lot of people burn out and
she hasn't and and i applaud her for
that but she really i think that's
her just being open to being the fun and
silly person that she is i think she's
actually sharing a lot of herself with
you guys unbeknownst
uh but that sense of play she naturally
has
yeah
divine says the truth she's just uh
she's um
you know she's the type of person
that i don't want people doing this but
there's a she's the type of person that
you can mess with you can you know
riff back and forth she's very cool very
funny
just down to earth all those silly
cliches that we
but it's actually true
which is actually but it's actually true
she's a very cool person
patty
i would say that sandy is very game
um to ad-lib and improvise and she's a
natural it is very it was very inspiring
to see her
um
how just
as you too divine like when all most of
my scenes are with divine divine and
joan and it was
like seeing you and sandra act together
was like i felt like it sucked me into
it because i felt like oh
because you're just gabbing in between
takes and like joking around and then as
soon as it started i was like oh i'm
with two like incredible actors and i
need to stop like
thinking about when i'm gonna take my
next diarrhea
and i need to be in the scene oh yeah
that was the thing because you know we
were on the island so that's
real stuff yeah that much got it there
wasn't matriculate and then but it
totally never really did it's a big deal
for her not to think about taking her
next diarrhea so that is and we
commended you and we said go through you
and keep doing that oh yeah because
you know
um i'm thinking about it right now
normally normally that's her state
when's my next diarrhea when's my next
diarrhea as soon as this goes off that's
what she starts saying but not in
dominican republic how do i say it like
that in the dominican republic you were
like i'm not thinking about diary at all
we're like good for you patty what a pro
what a gd pro and i said i may be a pro
but i'll never be a pro like sandy yeah
never
none of top that that's what you could
that's the takeaway from this interview
and if any people if you you take away
from this these three guys we don't
think about having diarrhoeas no no no
i have to stop i'm just going to say in
all my years of doing this this is a
first i'm just going to say thank you
and for real congrats on the movie